look I am crazy and and
continue sir no but I mean everybody's
crazy yeah and anybody that tells you
they're not crazy is crazy is even
crazier uh and so
um this is a crazy life on a weird
planet with all this fantastic stuff
we're trying to figure it all out uh and
I and I and I kind of got crazy when I
discovered all this stuff where I got to
where I thought everything was a
conspiracy and it's not a lot of times
it's just an aptitude or it's weirdness
uh but the globalists are trying to get
control of the esgs and the computers
and AI because they do want to control
it and so and they've got the most
control of anybody
and I think the people should start
having control about the choices we make
and what we do and that's why bycotting
what you guys do and supporting the show
because it was popular the day you
launched it and I watched a lot but I
mean the last few years and now you can
see when something blows up it's like
boom but that's now it's like
exponential so it grows from here to
here the first couple years it goes like
this then it goes 500 feet in the air
and we're you're now in that you know
now you can see that trajectory and I'm
not kissing your ass you can see it it's
exploding and it's a good show it
deserves it and it's one of the best
podcasts out there
and so I mean people need to support
what you're doing they need to support
Free Speech they need to know that it
takes courage to have Alex Jones on and
a lot of wimps don't do it uh and so
we're all big boys and girls we should
be able to actually hear what somebody
says I mean they used to interview you
know people like
Charlie Manson doesn't mean you agree
with Charlie Manson I'm not Charlie
Manson my point is we need to really
hear what somebody has to say and the
worst part about being de-platformed I
still have my hardcore great audience
listen every day at infowars.com and
on some radio stations around the
country other citizens people can find
it there but the biggest thing is they
can then misrepresent including uh deep
fakes I've had a bunch of deep fakes
done on me oh I'd say let's talk across
the story real quick I've had deep fakes
done on me and the guys it's online look
up Alex Jones uh took across the defect
and play it and uh and I've just talked
to him that day so I got another call
and then the CPA meeting and uh
I'll tell that story in a second the
point is is that is that
you don't get to respond on Facebook
Twitter Instagram CNN you know the old
days you can attack the New York Times
They call you no there's no it's all one
way so you're reading the New York Times
saying he's a white supremacist and I
mean I'm not I don't want to get in to
talk about my family all this kind of
stuff but we're the opposite of that
okay and it's it's very you know the
white supremise made a big deal about it
like I married a lady whose mother's
Jewish which actually makes her Jewish I
got three kids that that see themselves
Just As Americans and they're like are
we Jewish are we Christian because we're
Christian and we like you know that's
breaking news right there but the kids
are Jewish but the point is the white
supremacists well I've said this many
times are literally tell me how they
want to kill my family all the time so
I've experienced I get to be called a
white supremacist to the New York Times
for no evidence yeah and then meanwhile
you know my kids I guess technically
could you know commit a crime and run to
Israel the point is the point is the
point is whatever the point is is I'm
not ashamed of that but then at the same
time I talked about them years ago and
made all the Nazis come after me like
wow this is what it's like to like
associated with the Jews people really
want to kill you this is actually this
sucks this is wrong so but then the
media calls you white supremacy it's
just like I'm a white supremacist and
the white supremacist go look at white
supremacist websites I mean they hate me
more than almost anybody because I won't
make it all about you know hating Jews
or any other group all day I want to get
everybody for freedom and win so I'm
sitting there about a month ago five six
weeks ago in a CPA meeting at like five
o'clock I just actually talked to Tucker
that day
uh and
all of a sudden it was because he'd just
been fired you know a few weeks before
and uh all of a sudden hey it's Tucker
can you talk it by the way they spoofed
his number and the guy went online and
bragged about all this so so so he's the
numbers Tucker Carl's his number so he
had to get that number
go ahead
one of the most bizarre things that ever
happened to me in my life happened
yesterday afternoon at about 5 45. I was
sitting in an accounting oh you're
explaining it here I mean the guy hit
pause in an office go to Twitter uh
type in Alex Tucker Carlson uh what's it
called it his Twitter
it's called what's it called what's it
called when they do that it's a deep
deep fake Tucker Carlson Allen Jones
deep effect so so the point is it's
Tucker Carlson's voice and they have his
number so it shows up and he goes are
you all right and I said yeah he goes
well I want to you know do all these
sexual things to you and I go okay this
is not Tucker this is A.I and then the
guy goes you have to play this
can you find it or no please it was all
over the news type it into Google type
in uh Alex Jones Tucker Carlson deep
fake or Prank Caller AI uh deep fakes
Tucker Carlson
Yahoo news
so and then I called Tucker and he goes
yeah man there's a lot more stuff than
that going on this is horrible and then
they discovered who he was before he
came did you play it on that tweet did
you play it on that video or no or you
didn't play no that's the video the guy
that did it okay got it but it came out
later and then it was another Burger
because he said oh I got this long
conversation I faked Jones out no I go
this isn't Tucker this is an AI like 20
like 10 seconds in and then he hangs up
so so but they but the point was it's
like talking when I want to do this to
you I'll do that to you maybe it was a
40 second by the way this is how
conspiracy there was a rumor out there I
know you're not I'm just don't come at
me they're like oh Alex Jones he's gay
right I'm like what are you talking
about why would you like what yeah I
heard about him at the at the Bohemian
thing and then the talk I'm like he's
not he's married with kids no no he's
like no I heard it was it's like by the
way just so you know just so you know
the president of Microsoft we got to
wrap up the podcast we're 20 minutes
over the president of Microsoft the
president of Google every one of them
they said the biggest threat they're
concerned about moving forward is going
to be Ai and deep fakes deep fakes to be
specific okay deep fakes to be specific
let's explain somebody calls your mother
yeah and it's your voice and says hey
Mom I really need a thousand dollars if
you please give me the credit card yep
and mom gives it to you from your number
they've already have yours kidnap a girl
or or say they have her voice call them
say I'm kidnapped mommy give me money
yep so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
foreign